hello and bloops welcome to the city of
lynwood would pusher 2010 some are
prominent would push up renunciation I
mean score wise it's okay one win one
row okay my age 39 turn i th five year
he plays the absolute main line here g3
is what they normally do nowadays and
now f5 this is a bit in precise I
believe because now I get this this
Indians g4g for business g45 h 4 and so
on b6 mmm okay
I can go h4 I can you are three and many
ideas let's go H for my ideal scenario
is i get age 5 and h 5 g 5 34 the clamp
so i'll try to do that be 6 is a usually
a pretty bad structural decision because
i will never take on c5 anyway so be
takes is kind of it's never happening so
it's um it just limits his options ok so
g5 is a move now and then aged 5 is 1 1
way to play sometimes by they i can take
on c5 if I get this g5 Bishop g4 in its
11 very rare occasion that would
actually do that ok h5 you will probably
capture so I'll go g5 so what's now yeah
I guess I guess h5 huh let's do it
I guess if it feel so it's not a
complete deja vu but it's kind of close
to that something simple i had ahead on
the Portage's very recently in blitz
one issue is that on Bishop g4 guesses
check on d3 which is kind of this is
this is a pretty annoying actually so
take him and what now how do I get get
castled Quincy to that's not G forces
not so nice maybe just do this huh cover
g4 and it's not so easy now for him too
ok he it's he can cover g6 but we have
whatever movie plays it's probably not
something that he enjoys very much so my
idea was just Quincy to and castle yeah
that looks good
need to get cancelled we see one issue
now with this be six month if he
wouldn't have played b6 and would still
have like c6 and then then he could play
c6 and maybe take on d5 at one moment
and now c6 I can just take basically it
is just a purely negative move for black
didn't give them any benefits that just
took away options which doesn't mean
that I'm winning or anything white is
just quite a bit better here I'm playing
this in a slow way I just cancelling
first not rushing maybe now I have
Knight f3 as an additional option the
night coming to g5 now that eva is
protected I couldn't do it early as if i
was hanging so maybe this is an
additional option now but i also want to
castle oh it's a mysterious moment
what's the point here baby bishop to
have six and something i should have six
know yeah this is an interesting idea
can be played quite often in those in
those structures yeah I'm not going to
take the rook that's not not not even to
be considered Bishop g4 maybe
I mean okay taking the rook is probably
possible but it's not really high on my
agenda to grab material him ok so maybe
f3 just make it a bit more solid here I
can take this on a phone with the night
this is something that is possible like
92 and maybe then take it this disc this
can be an option I don't want to take
that in general because it opens up his
bishop on g7 the bishop under 7s
currently not doing anything but if I
take F for it clearly is coming poon is
coming to life this is also 493 m I'm
not necessarily interesting playin yeah
it takes I don't want to take I simply
don't I think I rather try to put
something on there five here
9h five Bishop inch 5 those moles I came
I'm not sure if I want to do a three
here
might be dangerous anyway I have to
decide on the move wants to push me five
mmm
I can take Nazi form
if I just keep it as a disk let's say I
do this this is very unconventional but
maybe it's just a good idea and take
this how does he open up the position i
don't see at the moment how he does that
maybe i just keep it like this
check
I just want to keep coming just want to
keep this piece is passive and neither
five is coming I didn't see that one
okay I should have taken on b5 first
time morning would have been would have
been a lot better actually
Green cb7 what the what the beep and 93
all of the Sun ok Jack I'll come on and
why don't buy donuts but why ever look
Vemma we're looking at this simple move
oh I'm such a [ __ ] I'm such a [ __ ]
unbelievable from this position just
completely winning yeah we know the deal
check but ah I simply hate this stuff
you completely dominate this game from
the one and then yes this nonsense
happens check black jacket yeah sorry I
don't care every don't care that was
such a one-sided game so I'm going to
win this on time and I have a look-see
for our what an idiot I am yeah around
yet it's very one-sided I just have to
probably take this on b5 and then play
nine f5 and this is basically over has
to give up the exchange yeah I mean it
was interesting play this looking
forward I simply never take and if I
don't take this like a sitting in this
strategically very dubious position he
has all those all those bad pieces
gentium it's just upon the position is
closed this was a slow way of playing it
with the night I'd f5 was also possible
already when he has to give the exchange
yeah the main issue he is actually the
whole opening if the here Black Knight
c5 is a mistake ready just like that he
has to go at five year I think and play
this position I cannot do this I think
there's f4 which is are getting like
lots of play normally I think it's taken
at night h4 is the thing or maybe Bishop
g5 first I'm not totally sure it this is
just not a good idea and now I have to
go back and this whole night aged 5 and
9 f six has not yeah does this didn't
didn't lead to anything energy for ya
and said b6 is just not good it just
Rob's black of options and white is a
lot better on there on the King side
here you're struggling and a different
option here is this move this this kind
of thing where white is trying to prove
that this is a piece down this can be
quite successful actually but the issue
with this is quite often that let's say
or dis black do some some kind of move
and let's say a three for example and
then like takes takes and then some look
at four and this often gets very messy I
mean why it is probably a lot better and
those pieces too kind kind of ridiculous
but it's also quite closed so i wasn't
sure i think this is this is a simple
way of playing it gives a gives a big
advantage yeah is that interesting
interesting move but i don't have to
take and this is always always some kind
of play maybe it's not objectively
enough but it's it's not easy in a
practical game okay thanks for watching
guys